what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe n you
I want to see the thing that you've got
inside here come out to have a big
impact on the world instead of help you
on your journey today we're gonna look
at six psychological tricks to make
people like you immediately number two
is my personal favorite and I left into
which one you guys like the best and as
always guys as you're watching if you
hear something that really resonates
with you please leave it down the
comments below put quotes around it so
other people can learn and when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick with yourself as well enjoy so
let's get into it
trick number one is match and mirror
rapport is power earlier today we said
anything you want to achieve anything
you want to learn master experience
there's somebody out there who has a
life experience the understanding the
network the capital the thing you need
to be able to achieve it but they're not
gonna give you what they want or they
don't give you what you want rather a
need until you first give them what they
want need and you're not even gonna find
out what they want need until you first
get in a relationship of rapport if you
don't do that you're never gonna learn
anything rapport aspire what is a
relationship of rapport rapport means
total responsiveness between people when
someone is totally responding to you and
you're totally responding then you're in
rapport there's that connection it's
that spark that happens in certain
communications or relationships now
everybody wants to create rapport have
it but most people only get rapport with
people who are like whom themselves and
they lose with everybody else which
means you got a very limited world so we
want to take it to a different level so
let's say for example if I said to you
right now guys I want you to go out to a
local restaurant or bar and I want you
to meet somebody and I want you to
develop rapport with them a connection
with them how many feel like you do that
no problem say I am and if you're not
raising your hand you're probably
selling yourself short of course you
could how would you do it though you'd
walk of this restaurant a bar you meet
somebody and you engage them in
conversation by asking a few what
questions now is it possible to ask a
few questions and have a conversation go
boom just die is that possible yes or no
so questions don't create rapport
questions or a tool use to dig for
something what are you digging for we
ask these questions you're trying to
find something in what that's right so
write your notes rapport is created by a
feeling of commonality rapport is
created by a feeling of commonality
rapport is created by a feeling of
commonality we people we feel like we
have something in common with someone
there's a spark now here's the problem
if we're porous creative affinity of
commonality most people try to get
rapport by using words but you've
already learned something what
percentage of our communication skills
are words what percentage seven percent
which means you're leaving at 93 percent
of your skills which is why most people
don't get rapport with a large number of
people yeah what do you do you walk in a
restaurant a bar and go hi what's your
name where are you from why are you here
and person says my name is Abbey I'm
from Rach I'm a terrorist I'm here to
kill people and you go amazing me too no
see words don't always work do they but
there is something that always works to
get rapport and that's something called
matching and mirroring matching and
mirroring now matching and mirroring
came about 35 years ago when it's we've
all done matching airing our whole lives
but the person who pointed out was
Milton Erickson dr. Erickson was a
genius what he did was he was a medical
doctor but he also was a psychologist
and a hypnotherapist probably the best
that ever lived and people will come to
see him who try to change everything
anywhere else in their life nothing at
work they see him for one session he'd
handle it and the reason is because he
understood something he understood that
you have both the conscious mind in his
subconscious mind and he knew the
subconscious is more powerful it's made
part that makes your heart beat a
hundred thousand times a day without him
to think about so he knew if he could
influence your subconscious mind he
could change anything and that's what he
did but here's how he did it he had
polio so he was in a wheelchair so he
spent an enormous amount of time study
people and they began to notice
something about human beings that when
human beings got together if they got in
rapport a relationship of responsiveness
they became like each other in a variety
of ways what he called they mirrored
each other
now I've taught this for 25 years I'm
sure you've heard of it and I've written
in my books and it's been taught in a
variety of other areas now but it's one
thing to know it intellectually or to
understand it's another thing to know it
what you're doing it and that's what I
want to get you to do tonight so you
have a real experience of it that you
won't forget but here's the basis of it
people like people who are like whom
themselves and people don't like people
who are not like themselves to be more
specific write this down people like
people who are like themselves or who
are like how they would like to be
people like people who are like
themselves or or how they would like to
be people like people are like
themselves or how they would like to be
so question I like you to think of
someone you really really like a lot and
then if you would raise your hand if
this person is either like you or
they're like how you want to be if
that's true is you can say I of course
that's why I like them now think of
someone you don't like I'm sure you like
everyone but if you once were a nun
spiritual person and felt these feelings
some of you don't like raise your hand
if they're not like you or they're not
like how you want to be if that's true
is your hand say aye
and that's the opposite people don't
like people who are not like them or are
not like how they want to be that's the
bottom line of it so this concept
Erikson noticed he used it in the
following way watch me if you came to
see dr. Erikson instead of talking to
you intellectually and trying to get
through to you he'd go right for the
jugular
by getting your nervous system connected
to him getting rapport so if you came to
him and you said dr. Erickson I don't
know this is a waste of time I've I've
tried everything and I don't know I
think I should just go he would do this
he'd go
I'm sure it looks that way on the
surface but you haven't tried this so
you haven't tried everything and I think
you should stay and the person would go
Oh something about this guy I like you
know he's not over the top you know what
I mean he's like really real there's
just somethin bout him that feels
down-home and real to me right if you
came to see him it's a dr. Erickson I've
tried everything it's a waste of my time
I'm out of here he'd say you sit down
you haven't tried everything you've not
done this before you're staying right
here
okay goes hey I like this guy's got some
spunk kick ass maybe you could do
something see he became like the pee
blues communicating with and what it was
is whatever they put out he sent the
same message back like biofeedback and
didn't train them to him so that when he
didn't told their unconscious what to do
their brain just did it that was his
power trick number to express positive
energy I had to show up and work with
the right attitude and with the positive
and and I actually had a t-shirt made
this and positive energy is a part of
your job description
right so the the idea that I want to
show up with the right energy I want to
show
we have energy because it's just hugely
important to approach everything and
everybody at every turn with the trick
number three be loving and kind ever let
anybody stop you but from believing that
it's cool to be kind that's the one
thing I feel like that I struggled with
so much was that I like to be loving and
kind and people often will try to act
like that's not cool that's corny that
all this type of stuff but I my heart
it's like I've always wanted to share
and be a loving person and all that kind
of stuff and that really stifled me
sometimes as he as a young teen and I
would really just tell myself don't stop
believing that those are good things
those are great qualities those aren't
bad qualities it might seem like that
because the cap type of people you
around but don't let that stop you from
being true
you know the truth chick number four is
have a sense of humor now primary focus
should be poems on earth but I think
that there should be some small amount
that's given over to the establishment
of of a colony on Mars and making life
multiplanetary that by small amount I
mean some number less than 1% of our
resources so you know it's it's not as
important as as say health care but it's
more important than like say cosmetics I
mean like I'm Pro come you know are in
favor of cosmetics I like them they're
great
but you know lipstick Oh colony on Mars
question that has been discussed over
the past couple of days should we be
considering one trips one way only trips
to Mars what's the best approach to
colonize the planet is it but what's
your review it's not socially acceptable
you think people will sign up to do it I
think there's plenty of people who sign
up for a warrior to Mars but maybe if I
could just have a show of hands who
wouldn't see there such an option I see
some not many or perhaps enough for a
couple of missions
simply enough I think it's sort of like
is it a one-way mission and then you die
or is it a one-way mission and you get
resupplied that's a big difference for
the second option yeah exactly but every
I think it's so it ends up being a moot
point because you want to bring the
spaceship back like these spaceships are
expensive okay if they're hard to bulls
and just leave them there so whether or
not people want to come back or not is
kind of like they can jump on if they
want but they need the space you're back
thank you
I mean kind of weird like it was like
huge collection of spaceships on Mars
over time really well if it's like we're
just in the back and of course was just
in the back speaking of crazy things
went went to Russia three times to
negotiate a deal to buy a couple of the
largest ICBMs in the Russian fleet a
strange experience get into that
negotiation well you talk to people and
know people and pretty soon you're
talking to the Russian rocket forces and
you know they turns out Russia's quite
quite a capitalist society and and so
I've better but it definitely had some
some weird meetings in places like that
I swear they looked like a Senate
sanitarium or something I don't know
it's just very hard we came back to the
theme of crazy yeah seriously this place
had padded walls why do you have added
walls it was weird and yeah and then I
had some sort of Russian guy we was
missing a front to started yelling at me
because his friend one of his front
teeth was think it was like spit flying
at me that it wasn't like this the
really bizarre right and that wasn't
what you thought I'm gonna build my own
rocket yeah
chick number five is embrace
vulnerability the biggest myth about
vulnerability is that it's weakness I
think a lot of people were raised to
believe that it was modeled I think
certainly in our culture we see that a
lot that to be vulnerable to be open to
be exposed is to be weak and the truth
is you know what I found in my research
is that vulnerability is not weakness in
fact I would argue that it's our
greatest measure of courage when we went
out and asked people what is
vulnerability we heard things like
vulnerability is the first date after my
divorce
vulnerability is starting my own company
vulnerability is taking responsibility
for something that went wrong at work
vulnerability is sitting with my wife
who has stage three breast cancer and
making plans for our young kids
vulnerability is taking my business
public you know the definition I use in
my work of vulnerability is simply
uncertainty risk and emotional exposure
vulnerability is about the willingness
to show up and to be seen even when
there are no guarantees and it's
interesting to me I mean one of the
things that I thought was really
interesting I gave a talk it's probably
a couple years now and it was being
translated by people doing American sign
language and they came up before the
talk started they said are there any
words that you're going to use a lot in
your talk that we should you know know
about that are might be different I said
well use the word vulnerability a lot
and they kind of there were two of them
they kind of look each other they said
oh we do this for vulnerability and I
said what does that mean they said it
means weak in the knees and then like
wow that's not how I talk about
vulnerability and she said well there's
only one other sign for vulnerability
and I said what is it and she said and I
said oh that's what I'm talking about
and so to me
vulnerability is our most accurate
measure of courage I mean it's pretty
powerful when I have 13,000 pieces of
data collected over 12 years that I
cannot find a single incident or story
of courage that was not completely
underpinned by vulnerability I think the
problem arises that if there are so many
little paradoxes with vulnerability and
one of them is that vulnerability is
courage in you but weakness in me when I
meet you it's the first thing I look for
in you but it's the last thing I want to
show you and me and so I think to really
put ourselves out there knowing that if
we do that enough we're going to fail I
just don't think it gets more courageous
than that and trick number six is
compliment others and last but certainly
not least is something that I do that is
a little trick all right it's like first
impression espionage because there's no
getting around like in somebody when
they actually give you a compliment when
I meet somebody for the first time I try
to look for something that I can
compliment them on all right because
automatically you complement them they
like you more it happens right because
when somebody
you a compliment you're like yeah you
just like a more it works gentleman and
then when they think of you next time
they're gonna think of that dude who
gave him the compliment that they
automatically like gentlemen here's the
deal first impressions we only have one
chance to make it so make yours count
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video
what was your favorite trick and why how
are you going to immediately apply this
somehow in your life for business leave
your thoughts down in comments below I'd
also love to know did I miss a seven
eight nine ten that you want to add to
the list share your thoughts in the
comments thank you guys again so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you that
sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]